et nous sommes en direct avec ian
brossât porte parole du parti communiste
français bonjour ian brossât
merci d'être en direct avec nous alors
on a l'impression que le groupe sanofi a
rétropédalé ce matin avec ses
déclarations
est ce que vous êtes du même avis
j'entends ces nouvelles déclarations il
reste qu'elle ne fait on pas oublier ce
qu'on a entendu hier et on voit là quand
même qu'il y a des réflexes qui sont
absolument insupportables enfin ce qu'on
nous a dit hier c'est que les français
seraient servis après les américains
parce que les américains ont mis plus
d'argent sur la table alors même qu'il
s'agit d'une multinationale française et
que la france verse énormément à sanofi
puisque sanofi bénéficie de plus de
temps millions d'euros de crédit impôt
recherche que 80% du chiffre d'affaires
de sanofi tu es du remboursement par la
sécurité sociale et donc tout cela je
crois est clair les logiques qui anime
ces grandes multinationales la rapacité
de ces grands groupes et qu'il est temps
de remettre un peu d'intérêt général
dans tout ça à laboratoire français
justement devrait-il priviligié son pays
d'origine à la base ce qui est certain
en tout cas c'est que on attendrait
d'une multinationale française qu'elle
serve effectivement les français et
surtout qu'on sorte de ces logiques
purement financière c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs le parti communiste
plaide pour une nationalisation de
sanofi et pour un pôle public du
médicament on parle de santé on parle de
question de vie ou de mort est dès lors
qu'on parle de questions aussi
importantes que celles là on devrait
sortir de logique purement financière de
logique qui font des logiques de
rentabilité
on devrait substituer à ces logiques la
des logiques d'intérêt général et dès
lors que ça relève de l'intérêt général
ça devrait relever du service public est
d'ailleurs nos parlementaires relaieront
cette exigence d'un pôle public du
médicament
alors on sait que le groupe sanofi a
touché ces dernières années
énormément de crédit d'impôt pour la
conte et la compétitivité et l'emploi
cette déclaration est d'autant plus
choquant aujourd'hui selon vous mais
bien sûr c'est un groupe qui vit aux
crochets de l'état
c'est un groupe qui ne vit que par ce
qu'ils y allaient les subsides publics
de l'état français par le crédit impôt
recherche par le cic eux par le
remboursement de la sécurité sociale et
donc au bout du bout on a une entreprise
qui se gavent d'argent public français
qui est donc l'argent des français et
qui dans le même temps ne s'engage pas à
les servir même s'il ya aujourd'hui une
espèce de rétropédalage nez et donc je
crois que tout ça doit nous inviter à
aller vers un service public du
médicament parce que sur un sujet aussi
important que celui là la seule question
qui doit compter c'est la santé de nos
concitoyens
ian brossât merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes porte-parole du parti
communiste français